OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
Hey, how's it going everyone?
LWIAY
YouTube's most fashionable show,
where we review PewDiePie memes.
That's right, everybody
the greatest memes of all time.
Who made it to the ultimate glory of eternal life..
by submitting their meme to Meme--  Pew News--
What? Help me. *giggles*
It's all the same.
It's all the same anyway,
No one really cares.
Let's review the first PewDiePie meme everybody.
LWIAY INTRO PLAY (BY DAY BY DAVE)
🎶Leave Your entries in the subreddit bros🎶
🎶and i'll watch submissions🎶
🎶 in the next episode of LWIAY!🎶
If oil is made from decomposed dinosaurs and plastic is made from oil...
plastic dinosaurs are made from real...
Dinosaurs...
Wait a minute. Oh my god
Ok, ok
This is epic
Son: "Dad, why is my sister's name 'World Peace'?"--
Oh, it's another one of those.
[Father:] "Because it's your mother's biggest dream."
[Son:] "Thanks, Dad."
[Father:] "No problem, 7 upvotes."
You guys post the worst memes I have ever seen.
How am I supposed to laugh at this?
Do you want anything positive for me to say about this?
It's garbage, It's pathetic.
Unless this has 7 upvotes,
then DON'T WASTE MY TIME!
Meme 👏 Correction 👏
Do it right. Go to your room.
I /could/ save your life...
BUT AM I GONNA?
👏👏
Buy my life saving Package. You can get a docdom and a wristband.
"The patient is laughing with the doctor. He wants to die."
Who doesn't?
Oh my god. Yes. I love this sketch.
[The one] where we see him slap everything.
*People, car roofs, exclaiming while Larry, the car salesman, slaps all of them*
This is the first time I've seen a decent version of this meme.
That must have been so fun to film.
Wow, car salesmen sure slap a lot of roofs on vehicles.
"This is the only car slap meme I actually thought was kind of funny, just because I like the original video."
Is this me???
You guys are learning! I am actually quite proud.
"Every meme after 10 minute mark is a bon--"
NO!
NOOoooooo!
All right, wait, we got a new LWIAY intro?
*beeps in the pitch and rythm of the intro*
Hey, heh
I don't know how that works, but that's pretty cool.
"PewDiePie leaked analytics!"-
Oh my god, I thought it was real!
"Your estimated revenue: 0.--" Oh, it is real!
It is real everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
It sure is wonderful to entertain millions of people.
That's right, I am entertaining with my own original content and I get so much back
You know, I don't need the money I get so much back from you guys. That's really all I need to thrive
That's really all I need to live. Please just more comments telling me what a piece of garbage I am
What the hell was that? This is so sad. Alexa play Despacito 2? (Alexa): Playing Despacito 2
Dame tu cosita uhh, uhh, dame tu cosita uh, ay
I like how some memes just keep lingering forever. They just never die
That's how you know it's a good meme. The oldest subscribers of Pewdiepie
Well, are they still subscribed though? SP RVD Ajax the beast?
Tex
cakti and
Arza. Dude. I remember having 19 subscribers and I was so happy. I was so happy. What a wholesome moment
I was wondering how many on PewDiePie subs are dead and it's gone and it's gone everybody
Thank you very much. This is why we can't have nice things. Hey, you marrying that meme review guy?
No English, I'm Italian. Sorry totally forgot
Lmao yeah
You're marrying that meme review guy? It actually works. Whenever I'm hungry
I just do this and she immediately starts cooking pasta. That's not even a joke. That's just truth. She makes great pasta
I don't know what to tell you man. What do you think of marrying -?
My simply I'm joke it's a joke. I love you so much. Ah
Getting paid an everyday struggle everybody.
Well now what YouTube does is that it's all green everything
I upload is green, but then you check the revenue and it's like congratulations! This video is monetized.
You made $2 on these millions of views.
Thank you. I'm glad it was monetized instead of when it's yellow. This makes all the difference for me
I can look in the camera like everyone else but am I gonna?
I said it was a self timer. And I said, this is a total Christian rock band shot
We should really embrace that spirit I go for it. Everyone else is like eh
I commit to the meme. What's feel is looking for original content. I will never
instigate violence against my faithful audience
Okay, but am I gonna?
Keep meme-ing me and see where things are GOING
*Felix smacks himself with his kawaii anime sword like a retard*
See? It's real. I'm level 5 Kendall story. I know how to mess you up. There's photo is from
1955 it did it was called a few seconds before happiness
9 year olds Brad one and two bonus me
Bonus meme is dead. Wake up
Grow up stupid 9 year olds clinging to the past. LWIAY is I'm coming. Oh my god
Stop that meme
Stop it. Stop that meme. I don't want to see it. I don't want to see it anymore
Okay, it's bad enough being Swedish. Okay as it is
When Pewds makes two handshakes successfully at once
*bling* At one time
Good, good. We thought we'd start today with a little Behind the Scenes
Alright. Alright. So Felix, this is Nikki.
Uh, she's a big fan. - Nice to meet you.
So nice *bling* meeting you
Awesome!
UGH! *2nd Pewds starts clapping*
*starts laughing*
Yeess!
(2nd Pewds) Bravo!
(both Pewds screaming Bravo and clapping)
See, you know
I know how to shake hand, it's when it gets into this area where I'm like well
I don't know what you want me to do here. Can we just shake hand please? Listen, I'm white, okay
I don't know how to do it.
SKRATTAR DU! FÖRLORAR DU!
No, please no world cup memes it's too strong. It hurts too much
Hey, man, can you show me the answer for the fourth one? Yes, I can but am I gonna?
Yes, this gets a solid ten out of ten. Let it began but I'm a-gonna mean browsing reddit by yourself
*Laughs in Swedish * No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Watching a Swedish
Billionaire. Thank you very much browse reddit. That's how its done everybody. You know, why because you have no friends
Let's just keep let's just get that out of the way. Okay, it's alright, I don't have friends either
I should really call it. What up, my bros –my brothers. We're best friends right emotional manipulation
For more views
I work for–it worked for five years guys. People still wanted me to do it. It's your own fault. I don't know what to tell you, this
listen, I was
I was always honest
About it
But I am I gana
I hope you guys are enjoying this video so far
if you are make sure to leave a like and
Smash that subscribe button if you're new because we do this every single week guys
I know it's a lot of work for me to go through these reddits so I really do appreciate all the support that I can
Possibly get we're doing the last page
If you want to submit your meme
Check out a link in the description, earn the ultimate glory to put on your curriculum. My meme was on meme review
I mean LWIAY whatever it's the same thing basically.
Hard to swallow pills Pewdiepie doesn't kill memes
We just stop posting them because we know he won't review them anymore and we are desperate for his attention
I don't know if I agree with that
I think it's more like once you explain the joke to so many people it kind of loses its value
Unless there's more ways to play on it
I think if anything if a meme doesn't survive meme review it's a
Testimony that it probably wasn't that great of a meme to begin with. That's the truth bomb for you guys
I dropped three in a row now. You guys got a hit double subscribe for that if you want more
Okay, you think you're so clever? Huh? You think you're so smart? Okay
Do you
GRRR
ARRRRRRRGH (Felix losing it)
Damn it!
Fine you got me one time one time out of what? 20 episodes?
50 episodes one time you got me, whatever. I don't care. You're still 9, okay
You're still 9 can't believe Pewds killed Sweden by accident. Come on Sweden
That was good actually, you know
When I tweeted out: "Can't wait to be surrounded by crying people here in England."
As soon as Sweden lost everyone was like
This didn't age well. This didn't age well
This did'd-d-d-d-d-d
That meme only works if you give it some time
Okay
You're supposed to take a meme from the past and then something happens
In the future and then you can go "this didn't age well" You can't go 20 *** minutes
and then go "this didn't age well"
It's not funny everyone tweeted it to me and I'm like, you're not funny
Okay, you stupid and then yes, it looks like it did age well!
Because England lost and I was hoping they would win because then I could rub it in more in the finals
I want people to suffer
What's up, man? You're okay. This is the top meme. What's up, man? You try to make an earth sandwich, bro
I don't know what you're trying to say
I'm in America or in India if we both simultaneously put a piece of bread on the ground. Boom! Earth s sandwich
I think I don't understand the game. Now I understand. I'm ready, bro. Me too. Great
That was it for this week's LWIAY I love this so much
*clap* *clap* (MEME REVIEW)
This makes me genuinely happy, thank you guys for all the memes
I really really do appreciate it and thank you for watching my videos every single day. I'll see you tomorrow
Good Bye! sleep tight my 9 year olds